[Aplausos]
que tipo de homem você aquele tarzan
tanque e grita para resolver as coisas
o homer simpson que todos os problemas
da mulher dele ou do cheque
o grupo que resolve as suas coisas a seu
jeito da sua forma
pois é se não existe aqui infelizmente
existe na sociedade
eu também tive uma formação machista
exógena homofóbica sexista certa forma
isso passou por dentro de mim como se
fosse uma coisa bem natural bem normal
pois meus avós agiam assim meus pais e
eu recebi essa educação
até que um dia fazendo uma trilha
junto com colegas eu só tenho uma pedra
e essa pedra provocou uma dor muito mas
muito grande
eu me agachei e comecei a chorar e o
líder então parou a trilha e me chamou
de mulherzinha molenga e veio até
mim para eu levantar e perguntou o que
eu estava falando fazendo eu estava
chorando que eu não era não só nega
van damme eu tinha então ali deixado o
sentimento de dor me tomar quanto os
homens deixa o seu sentimento de dor
sair pois é
fomos para debaixo de uma árvore
conversamos por cerca de duas horas
sobre lágrimas sobre sentimentos sobre o
que é ser homem na sociedade
a vida foi passando e eu me dei conta
então que ser homem e se mostrasse ser
forte e se ser sem sentimentos sem
mostrar o que é tudo dentro da gente
a vida foi girando girando
e eu acabei por incrível que pareça
trabalhando em um garimpo é o garimpo
aquele ambiente saudável né harmônico né
onde todo mundo trata todo mundo o favor
da licença mas o garimpo foi muito bom
também
foi um lugar da segunda escuta e eu pude
escutar o que ele estava fazendo ali
junto àqueles homens todos garimpando
procurando o ouro ganância riqueza
destruição então eu percebi que aquilo
não ia levar nenhum lugar
foi aí que eu resolvi voltar à
civilização na cidade e fazer filosofia
quando eu disse isso para o meu pai
pronto vou criar um vagabundo
ele perguntou pra que serve filosofia
que serve filosofia
pra que serve um desafio mas o filho não
serve pra nada
todo mundo tem uma filosofia pois a
filosofia está dentro da gente então
estudando filosofia eu caí em um grupo
que estudava há a questão da sexualidade
que queria pesquisar a epidemia da aids
na cidade de são paulo
então lá vai eu mais uma vez em
aventurar foi para as ruas de são paulo
à noite investigar prostitutas travestis
michês todos os profissionais do sexo
na faculdade o nosso grupo era conhecido
como os protocolos
então a gente fez o dois anos essa
investigação na cidade de são paulo mas
na hora da discussão dos relatórios e
equipe
eu levantei uma pergunta falta uma
personagem para ser entrevistada nesse
projeto todo mundo perguntou qual eu
falei o cliente
o homem eu falei é precisamos entrevistá
saber por que um homem entra numa
situação de risco porque o homem força a
situação de violência porque o homem
paga ou não paga
tá na mão e olha descobrir muitas coisas
a descobrir principalmente que ser homem
nessa sociedade é um castelo de
fantasias ea gente vive e se apoiando
nesse castelo de fantasias que a essa
questão das masculinidades ela precisa
ser mais investigado
ela precisa ser mais discutida então eu
comecei a pesquisar e entender como é
que se dá esse processo de formação das
masculinidades o que que é o homem que
eu me sinto como nessa busca acabei
participando de um seminário sobre
gênero e sexualidade na federal do rio
de janeiro no auditório their 100
mulheres apenas dois homens e eu
levantei a mão sobre a questão de gênero
se gênero é relacional porque não se
estuda sobre o homem pois na situação de
violência que é o responsável
então como é que um homem não está aqui
não podemos estudar sobre o gênero sobre
a masculinidade
naquele momento todo mundo estranhou
porque estudar homens estudar aqueles
que são os donos do poder
e é justamente temos que estudar essa
pessoa isso ser humano porque ele se
coloca neste lugar e aí nesse estudo de
gênero
eu fui cada vez me aprofundando cada vez
buscando mais elementos e pude ver que
existe uma coisa na sociedade chamada
patriarcado que legitima esse lugar do
homem na sociedade legitima esse lugar
do poder e o próprio homem se torna
prisioneiro desse lugar
a gente nem sabe porque assim mas tem
que ser assim
eu nem sei por que eu tenho que esconder
o choro porque somos refratários a
expressar nossos sentimentos
nessa
nesse processo em santo andré
começamos a fazer um trabalho de
sexualidade masculina de paternidade de
saúde sexual e reprodutiva e todos
lembram aqui há bem pouco tempo atrás né
o que aconteceu com um homem que batia
ameaçava uma mulher pagava-se uma cesta
básica serviço comunitário tentava um
muro de escola isso educava alguém de
forma alguma
foi quando então uma conversa
começamos a atender esses homens que
agrediram as mulheres como era a rotina
qual era o perfil como como isso começou
a acontecer quase de forma espontânea
assim eu nem sabia o que estava
acontecendo pois muitos homens que
cometiam violência antes da lei maria da
penha
eles cometiam uma duas três
tinha um cara que estava tirando um
diploma de mestrado porque no mesmo ano
e há duas três vezes
o fórum contra aquela contra outra
companheira então pesquisamos a
metodologia eu tive que nos campos de
futebol
eu tive que nas sociedades amigos de
bairro eu tive que nos sindicatos
eu tive que ir aonde os homens estava
escutá los entender esse processo
entender como que se constrói essa
masculinidade de não aceitar a igualdade
entre homens e mulheres
e esse processo é bem rico pois quando
surgiu a lei maria da penha
a gente já tinha o básico a gente já
sabia que era necessário acolher esses
homens pois numa sociedade punitiva e
vocês devem saber as nossas cadeias
elas não transforma ela só reforça
claro eu queria pegar aquele homem que
ameaça que manda mensagem que dá avisos
pois é se o man essa forma de prevenir o
feminicídio a morte das mulheres é
atuando na primeira denúncia que a
companheira ex companheira namorada
noiva faz e esse projeto
ele começou a ganhar um corpo
ele começou a ganhar mais visibilidade e
ele se estendeu
ele começou a transformar uma
metodologia que até então não se tinha
de escutar o homem escutar o homem
agressor sim escutar um homem agressor
pois quando esse homem é indiciado e ele
começa a participar dos grupos
ele é convidado semanalmente a fazer
parte de um grupo com outros homens que
também agrediram as suas companheiras e
nesse processo de escuta durante 16
encontros ele não chega mansinha no
primeiro encontro não lhe chega como se
tivesse uma focinheira sabe ele chega
com sangue nos olhos
acreditando que tudo aquilo é invenção
da companheira
acreditando que está sendo injustiçado
porque teve que comparecer à delegacia
teve que se explicar
teve que dar um depoimento teve que
falar então nosso grupo é uma proposta
de erradicar a violência com esses
homens agressores
no primeiro encontro a gente chegando
ninguém vai falar eu acreditar
uma mulher começou a estudar depois que
criou os filhos e ela tava indo muito
bem na faculdade progredindo fazendo
novas amizades
clareando a sua consciência o que
aconteceu
o cara com muitos se une com muita
insegurança queimou todos os livros leva
quando ele fala isso com outro homem que
cometeu outro crime
esse homem também reagem mas você
poderia ter queimado a vida dela
a mágica é essa fazer com que o outro
homem que cometeu um outro crime também
perceba que aquele crime ele poderia ter
cometido e assim numa roda de conversa
não para passar a mão na cabeça de
ninguém pois nós tivemos um homem lá que
falou por favor me levem para a
delegacia não quero ficar aqui
vocês são torturadores sementes pois a
gente faz um processo onde ele vai
revendo a sua estrutura ele vai
aprendendo acilve aprendendo a ouvir de
uma maneira transformadora aprender que
aquele ato aquele puxão de cabelo
aquele grito aquela ameaça você não vai
sair de casa até mesmo uma mulher que
conseguiu um emprego bom e ela precisava
se a ter uma aparência melhor ela
comprou alguns vestidos pois o trabalho
exigir sabe o que ele fez com o vestido
dela picotou todos os vestidos ficou
cortou
ele está cortando o que está cortando os
sonhos a dignidade
ele está cortando a cidadania dessa
mulher
então esse homem quando relatou que o
outro também começou a escutar os dois
começaram a perceber que isso poderia
crescer e é esse momento de identificar
esse ato de ver
foi o ato de transformação
eu e um colega também quando estávamos
disputando um homem isso em são caetano
de repente ele levanta e fala é vocês
fizeram com que eu desistisse de matar a
minha mulher e eu olhei assim no meu
colega nosso jogo entre olhão e assim
falando isso dá certo
uau mil
e aí o que acontece os índices mostram
antes de participar desses grupos
o número de reincidência batia quase 90%
pois não existe uma forma educativa e
pedagógica sócio-cultural de
desconstruir esse machismo
o que a gente criou reduziu para cerca
de 11 ou 7%
em alguns lugares 2% o índice de
reincidência
o homem quando participa desse processo
de todas as sessões de todo o ciclo
ele abre mão dessa violência
ele abra mão porque ele se vê numa
fantasia numa lógica do medo numa lógica
machista patriarcal que ele não
compreende que a principal vítima é ele
mesmo
por isso é necessário despertar e hoje
nós temos um projeto chamado tempo de
despertar tempo de despertar para si
mesmo para essa sociedade para esse
modelo de sociedade onde as mulheres
estão aí participando plate ano
conquistando mudando o jeito de ser da
sociedade
esse projeto dê tempo de despertar na
cidade de taboão da serra
ele foi institucionalizado
nós conseguimos uma lei municipal
tornando obrigatório que haja pelo menos
dois grupos por ano de homens que
cometeram violência contra as suas
companheiras namoradas noivas e eu
acredito que isso é só o começo
só o começo de uma mudança muito
significativa para que possamos nós
homens entender que o feminismo faz bem
feminismo não é uma luta contra o homem
o feminismo é uma possibilidade de uma
sociedade igualitária onde todas essas
construções e ser o homem forte do rio
sejam jogadas por terra e nós homens
possamos andar numa rua quando a mulher
vem na sua frente ela não precisa mudar
de calçada
com certeza essa mulher já foi assediado
como é que um homem pensa que uma
buzinada bifum vai ser entendido pela
mulher como um elogio
como é que uma cantada no assédio sexual
pode fazer com que a mulher se encante
por esse princípio
então de fato tudo isso impactou o
projeto tempo de despertar ele prima
pela capacidade de escutar mas é uma
escuta transformadora pois a sociedade
precisa mudar
em todos os ambientes e hoje vários
grupos estão abertos aqui na cidade de
são paulo
em outras cidades atuando com essa
metodologia com essa prática
com esse momento de perguntar a nós
mesmos homens e mulheres o que é ser
homem na sociedade
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]